By the way, Mr. Fumi, it's not good to waste money
like this. I don't think it's a good idea to let the two of you fight one another in the future. If it's a
monster, I should be able to help in the
fight.  You should be able to pay it
anyway, so please don't loosen the purse strings any more
.
I'll do it, so please use it.I can't read the characters in this
world.Oh yeah
The
padi hero seems to have an aptitude for healing and support magic. Your Ojou-
chan has light and dark magic
.  Music]
We can afford to summon magic
This is a service that the window has taken care of I
really want to raise a crystal ball, but it wo
n't fall apart If you use a crystal ball, you can learn only one magic sealed there I've never heard of
it
I heard that there were some orders for Yusho-sama, but hey,
it's probably given to heroes other than type O.
I
can do my best
Thank
you Thank you